[Applause]
celebrity income breakdown it's also
called George Washington's at douche I
don't know why they made that but they
did for example this is interesting Paul
Ryan we looked it up Paul Ryan 65% of
his money comes from speaker the House
salary 25 percent comes from book
advances in investments 10% renting out
my hair to vampires to story that's a
true story
Barack Obama Barack Obama 20% publishing
fees for my book Dreams from My Father
20% publishing fees for my book The
Audacity of Hope
60% advance fees from my book sucks to
be you America yeah I looked into it
honey Boo Boo's mom I looked into it oh
for God's sakes I didn't do it yet
the Krauts like oh my god I showed a
photo of her
and there are like good work Coenen
honey Boo Boo's mom 20 percent radio 30
percent comes from television 50 percent
other electronic appliances I've pawned
did you really expect that one to have a
happy end it didn't turn out well it was
mom what a shock
Steve Bannon he's the guy running things
now Steve Bannon 50% White House salary
40% Breitbart ad revenues 10% playing
drunk Rudolph in Christmas parade Eric
trump one of the Trump sons Eric trump
1% hedge funds 99% successfully passing
through the birth
put him over there Steven Seagal Steven
Seagal I just like the picture I'm sorry
Steven Seagal wearing pajamas Steven
Seagal 20% film acting 20% TV acting 60%
selling my sweat to olive oil companies
sympathy for Steven Seagal that's hard
to do yeah yeah Rudy Guiliani this is
interesting check it out
20% speaking engagements 20% consulting
fees 60% payments for shouting escaped
zoo animals back into their enclosure
r2d2 big Star Wars Star yeah 50% of his
money comes from acting in these Star
Wars films 15% royalties from Star Wars
merchandising and get this 35% tazing
rich Japanese businessmen in the
Jennifer Sean Spicer White House press
secretary check it out 60% of his money
comes from press secretary salary 25%
private consulting 45% speaking fees 30%
know your math is wrong 95 percent no
further questions have a good day
and finally Melania Trump 40% please 35%
help 25% me and there you go
you
you